thank you very much for inviting me this
is a lot to think about already a great
group of remarks I'm happy to be here in
this very room because unlike the
engineers and so forth this is where I
spent an enormous proportion of my
graduate career at Yale which is at the
in the art gallery itself and it really
is the reason I am where I am today and
the reason I came here in 1981 I came
from Harvard with a BA in the history of
art and I knew I wanted to do modern art
and graduate students at Harvard said to
me she want to do modern art you have to
go to Yale and that had to do with
faculty who were here there was
principally Bob Herbert and Anne Hanson
both who were very well known to be
great teachers as well as scholars and
who also and this was the most important
thing for me were very active in
organizing exhibitions writing
exhibition catalogs for the yale
university art gallery and whereas at
harvard like at yale the art gallery the
fog art music scuze me art museum in
that case was where the art history
classes were held and the same is true
here as you know that was a very or as
you may know that was a pretty
traditional looking 19th century museum
building kind of allah temple on a hill
though the hill was very small in
cambridge but I came to New Haven and
saw this leak on building and saw these
bertoia chairs and knoll upholstery I
thought yeah this is this is who I am
this is where I want to be and being in
this very building with all the Louis
Kahn ethos implied was instinctively
right and when i came i wasn't even well
informed enough to realize that forget
about the professors or the edifice but
it was the collection of this museum
that was really um as you may know the
first Museum of Modern Art in the United
States unlike the place where i am now
which is always considered to have been
that moma was founded in nineteen twenty
nine but a woman named Katherine dryer
two years before that had established
what she called the socio Tay and a neem
well ten years before that had
established it the Soviet anonym was an
organization she founded with her
partner's man ray and Marcel Duchamp and
she she was a German immigrant in
Brooklyn began buying hand over fist
works of Modern Art that um at that time
did not take a wealthy person to buy by
the hundreds and Marcel Duchamp to make
a very long story short um is the one
who had vised her in 1953 when she died
to leave that whole collection to Yale
University since her utopian dreams of
making it into a real museum of modern
art in new york city didn't come through
but the whole concept of that kind of
collection started with her because she
ended up moving to Connecticut ended up
at Yale and it's all those works that
are on the walls today I paid a visit
before I came down here um great great
works by all of the classical heroes of
Modern Art who at that time quickly
became if they had not been already my
heroes the kind of thing that we did in
my classes to prepare exhibitions is
something very few graduate schools of
our history can offer you for example
one thing I remember very well is going
to a museum studies class led by Alan
chest at the director of the art museum
the art gallery and we all had as an
assignment to write an essay on a
painting in the collection and that sa
would appear in
book called something like selections
from the yale university art gallery
which was nothing to him a lot of
publications like that coming go during
the course of the years but for me it
was an immense experience mine was
Picasso's the first step this mother
cubist mother holding this crazy cubist
baby and you had to write something like
300 or 400 words on the painting and I
did it and I remember reading it to my
roommate a medical student um by the way
who although I didn't marry her she is
to this day my best friend and she just
lighting up like the fourth of July and
saying WOW I couldn't see that painting
couldn't maybe could have told it was a
mother and a baby but probably not what
a fabulous thing now I love this
painting too and just at that moment
where that was one moment where I was
just like yep this is what makes me
happy and so took the courses and so
forth here but knew I wanted to work in
a museum so literally the day after my
oil my oral exams here started work at
moma in the painting and sculpture
Department as a curatorial assistant
figured that I would make sure that this
was a good idea before I finished went
went on to work on the PhD then not
surprisingly got into museum work
realized it would be smarter to stay
working in the museum then come back to
school as which I had thought about but
it also hit me that you didn't have to
be brilliant to look around the museum
of modern art and realize that all of
the heads of the departments were men
and everybody else was a woman and that
all of those men had PhDs and none of
the women had one this is the mid
eighties and if i was going to want to
be one of those heads of the
department's i had better get the PhD so
i did that while i was working for a
stat moment then at the philadelphia
museum in the 90s and one of the things
that made
very very special in that way was I
think sort of stragglers like me who
knew they wanted to do the thesis but
we're not going to do at a conventional
time frame for me it was seven years I
guess since I arrived that I then handed
it in and not in situ that they made
this possible and in fact what was also
made possible for me at Yale working
with Bob Herbert was I did a
dissertation on a contemporary artist
Joseph boys a German artist for at that
time PhD programs pretty much stopped at
something like the point where Pollock
and Rothko came along today it's a
completely different story if you come
to the art history department here
you'll find people doing PhDs on artists
who aren't even 50 yet but at that point
that was considered a no-no and yet even
though it was a field that my advisor
himself knew very little about he told
me a great anecdote about the one time
he met Joseph voice when he was in
bizzle Dorf and said go ahead and that
freedom was something that I appreciate
still a great great deal the legacy of
the yale art gallery is unique in terms
of not only the art history program here
but the way it interacts with the school
of art and architecture of course and
just this morning at MoMA I had a visit
from an art history alumna from Yale who
had been in the program at the same time
that Richard Serra was a Joseph Albert
student josef albers student in the art
school and she brought me a collage that
Richard that she had bought out of the
student art show on made out of leaves
literally autumn leaves with some paint
smushed around holding the leaves
together and she had a note of
authentification from sarah saying yeah
i did this in 1962 at yale and she said
you know would we like it for a momen to
go with the two you know 17-ton steal
things by richard serra that also are
there
and you know absolutely this was
wonderful but you know I thought wow
that's pretty amazing coincidence that
i'm on my way to New Haven and here's
this but also at the moment for example
i'm working with class oldenburg for a
show on his work of the 60s that will be
at MoMA next year and some of you may
remember in nineteen-sixty-nine when he
put his lipstick on caterpillar tracks
up here at Yale that you may not know
was his very first outdoor monument and
it was at the invitation of the
architecture grad students it together
with Vin Scully who called this guy in
New York who they knew had done
wonderful proposals for these public as
he call the monuments for a few years
but never had occurred to him that
someone would actually invite him to
build one um so it happened to great
fanfare and of course great notoriety
here at Yale but he talks about it so
vividly today 40 some years later that
it's an astounding reminder of the
legacy of this place not only on the
students who went here but so many
artists who the art gallery or the art
program were affected by so that's a
very present kind of way in which the
Yale experience doesn't leave me